there's a very interesting and
disturbing article in Vice that I would
encourage all of you to read about
anti-vaxxers now wanting Revenge
political revenge and legal revenge and
what's extraordinarily disturbing about
this is that it doesn't make any sense
and it's very dangerous and so I'm not
going to tell you everything that is in
this article but the article is written
by Anna Merlin it's part of motherboard
which is like the tech
um side I guess we would say advice and
there's a particular part that I want to
point to here now the subheading of the
article says buoyed by the purported end
of a pandemic that continues to kill
thousands anti-vaccine activists now vow
to punish their enemies these people
said one need to go to prison
there's a particular section of this
article that is very scary okay and it
reads major anti-vaccine figures are now
seizing their chance to enact what they
see as Justice and do a little
fundraising and image burnishing in the
process besides Big Trees non-specific
legal threats we have Children's Health
defense the most moneyed and influential
anti-vaccine organization in the U.S led
by Robert F Kennedy Jr CHD is often
involved in strange and frequently
doomed litigation but recently and with
much fanfare it launched a new one an
antitrust lawsuit against major news
organizations and social media Outlets
which they accused of conspiring to
collectively censor online news about
covid the defendants included frequent
anti-vax targets like the Washington
Post and BBC the plaintiffs are a
veritable who's who of people making
bogus hosts Health claims including CHD
itself Thai and Charlene Bollinger who
run websites and still sell products
devoted to making bogus claims about
cancer and vaccines Jim hoft who founded
right-wing news site Gateway pundit and
Joseph Mercola who I've spoken about
before a long time figure in the Natural
Health World who's been a major funder
of the anti-vaxx movement
um they now are going to try to seek the
Revenge they believe they are entitled
to now it's very important to understand
that the Vindication they are asserting
for themselves they are claiming the
anti-vacs are claiming they have been
Vindicated now
often and I know that this is hard to
believe often it's as simple as oh you
know what we were right they said the
vaccine prevented covid and it doesn't
boom okay
now only if you do no investigation
yourself and completely suspend all
memory of what took place for years
could you believe that in the real world
we have a more evidence-based
understanding not only of vaccines but
of covet and all of these different
things and so for example
when you take the claim they told us the
vaccine prevented covet and it doesn't
you have to remember three plus years
has it been three yeah more than three
years of History the original vaccine
meant to focus in on the original
variant was very good at preventing
transmission and infection meaning would
that original vaccine you were actually
very protected against getting coveted
at all as the virus continued to mutate
the effectiveness of the vaccine against
infection diminished this wasn't hidden
there was no cover-up it was all over
the news as soon as it became uh known
and over time the vaccine became less
effective down to most recently from the
latest studies I've seen essentially not
effective at all at preventing infection
or transmission the vaccine became
primarily a tool that will prevent you
from getting a sick and prevent you from
dying with relatively good efficacy
arguably saving Millions if not more
lives
that doesn't vindicate the anti-vaxx
people the anti-vaxx people were saying
the same thing all along what changed
are the circumstances of the virus and
the vaccines similarly they claimed to
be Vindicated over side effects
myocarditis pericarditis except they'll
never tell you the real data about the
risks of those conditions from the
vaccine versus the risks of those
conditions from covid that's something
they conveniently leave out they insist
that there were cover-ups about
hydroxychloroquine and Ivermectin and
zinc and vitamin C and vitamin D and all
these different things and they say they
won't even allow it to be studied but
you can look up and find endless
peer-reviewed studies about all elements
of that it seems as though maintaining a
good level of vitamin D generally
speaking is a good thing for fighting
off a lot of infections and that
includes covet that includes covet the
zinc uh zpac vitamin C thing does not
appear to be useful Ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine have now been studied
very much uh extensively not effective
on covid so the Vindication they claim
one could only believe if you either
aren't paying attention or aren't
actually looking for scientific
peer-reviewed data but that doesn't mean
they aren't going to ruin a lot of
people's lives with these lawsuits and
these calls for Retribution so read the
device article we'll link to it in the
description to the YouTube video for
this story and we'll talk more about it
as those lawsuits move forward